[Musique]
qui es-tu
mot d'amour en langue polynésienne
de quelle eau es-tu fait
et de quelle eau es-tu fait
je n'allais pas tarder à le savoir
j'avais 15 ans
j'ai désobéi à mon père et je suis parti
skier au première neige dangereuses dans
la poudreuse délicieuse
15 ans
c'est difficile de résister quand on a
grandi dans les Alpes
mais je suis tombé
j'ai sauté une barre rocheuse j'ai
miraculeusement attiré sur mes deux
pieds
mais mon talon droit a explosé
quand je suis arrivée à l'hôpital le
médecin qui m'a reçu avec mes radios m'a
dit tu sais je ne suis pas sûr que tu
vas remarcher en tout cas pas tout de
suite
mais au fond de moi
c'était si si je vais remarcher
vous ne savez pas exactement comment
mais je savais pourquoi
pourtant le chemin a été bien long
ça m'a pris 10 ans
j'ai fait toutes mes années lycées avec
un plâtre
et je suis même allé au sommet du Vésuve
sur le dos de mon professeur de latin
merci Monsieur de m'avoir porté si haut
alors que j'étais tombée si bas
ce fut ma première déflagration
sortie du cadre
ben oui je pouvais plus rien faire comme
les autres
pendant que mes copains ados de mon âge
des valets les fantastiques le mercredi
après-midi
pendant que mes parents partaient en
montagne le week-end moi je n'avais
d'autre choix que de rester cloué à la
maison
à supporter l'atroce douleur de mon pied
c'était comme une prison
imaginez un instant que votre énergie
interne soit comme de l'eau mon pied
était pris dans une bloc de glace
j'ai été mûri dans ma douleur
transit d'immobilité
vous savez plus quoi faire de mon corps
je le traînais derrière moi en fait
mon talon avait me disait ton implosé en
fleurs très poétique
jusqu'au jour ou d'opération en
opération
en reconstruction le ligamentaire et en
rééducation infructueuse
le chirurgien orthopédiste qui me
suivait
brillant et très humain m'a dit
Fabienne je sais que vous allez vous en
sortir j'ai confiance en vous
vous avez la ressource intérieure
j'étais vivante j'aurais pu me tuer dans
cet accident j'aurais pu me briser la
colonne vertébrale et pourtant j'étais
vivante je commençais à comprendre que
là où l'aide médicale s'arrêtait
peut-être comment c'est l'aide que
j'allais me donner à moi-même
et si j'écoutais cette ressource
intérieure d'en parler le chirurgien
si je regardais les cartes que j'avais
dans mon jeu
si je regardais ce que j'avais moi et
non pas ce que les autres avaient et que
je n'avais plus
alors j'ai vu
que j'avais une famille aimante qui
voulait m'aider même si ne sachant pas
toujours comment
j'avais la chance d'étudier et j'avais
des livres des livres des livres plein
ma chambre
ça me rappelle ce que m'a dit cette
petite fille à mon cours de méditation
du vendredi
madame tu sais les livres c'est le
paradis
ah oui explique-moi ça un petit peu
mieux
les livres c'est ma dignité c'est mon
calme
waouh une petite fille de 7 ans vous
vous rendez compte
c'était mon histoire les livres c'était
ma dignité c'était mon calme
j'avais soif de récits d'aventure et de
voyage j'avais soif de mots qui
résonnent j'avais soif de textes fort
j'avais soif de littérature et de poésie
j'ai dévoré les livres ils m'ont forgé
l'esprit et ils m'ont appris à aimer ma
vulnérabilité
ma vérité je n'avais qu'elle
je devais l'accepter
je ne pouvais plus supporter mon propre
poids sur mon propre pied donc ma
rééducation c'était d'accepter de peser
mon poids sur cette terre
et d'incarner ma présence
le premier qui m'a donné l'opportunité
d'incarner ma présence c'est mon
professeur d'histoire-géographie
il avait créé une section théâtre au
lycée et j'y suis allé
le théâtre
mais oui mais bien sûr le théâtre c'est
ce qui rend la littérature vivante
c'est ce qui décuple le mouvement du
texte c'est ce qui met le mot dans le
corps
mon premier rôle c'était un naufragé
assis dans un bateau ah bah au moins
comme ça pas besoin d'être debout
il scrutait l'horizon en attendant qu'on
vienne le sauver c'était un peu mon
histoire
et puis mes études de lettres et de
langue vivante me conduisirent à
Strasbourg grande ville de théâtre par
son théâtre national
dans le plus grand secret
j'ai présenté le concours d'entrée du
Conservatoire national de région et je
l'ai réussi
je suis entrée pour 5 ans d'études
pré-professionnelles pour devenir
comédienne c'était un des rares
conservatoires de France à garder un
prix de diction à côté du prix de
comédie
on revisitait la fontaine Victor Hugo
Musset Prévert je me régalais
et pour travailler mes textes j'allais à
la piscine à la piscine mais oui à la
piscine
pour dire mes alexandrins
et exercer ma colonne d'air pour aller
au bout du verre
et pendant que je nageais l'eau
massait mon pied
rallongez mes tendons mes muscles mes
ligaments je récupérais mes nerfs je
récupérerai ma mobilité
qui me massait me portait et me
rééduquer
j'avais une voix
je trouvais ma voix je redevenais une
jeune femme
dans son souffle
sur ses pieds debout créatrice de sa vie
c'est le moment qui a choisi un de mes
amis acteurs pour me dire tu sais
Fabienne pour jouer tous les personnages
il en faut du coeur
ne croyez pas si bien dire
cet été là ma maman a été tuée
balayée par une chute de pierre
sur le retour du Mont Blanc
ce fut ma deuxième grande déflagration
mais dans le chaos cellulaire qui m'a
envahi à ce moment-là
j'entendais ma voix
j'entendais ma verticalité
j'entendais la voix de ma maman qui me
disait tu as ta voix va et ne te
retourne pas
je l'ai vu une dernière fois en rêve
j'ai couru vers elle elle m'a pris dans
ses bras et puis elle m'a renvoyé dans
le monde des vivants
faire mon chemin
avec un message
au nord chaque petite partie de toi qui
veut vivre
cela te permettra toujours de reprendre
les rênes de ta propre vie
j'étais passionnée de théâtre
je suis devenue répétitrice pour mes
camarades je leur faisais travailler
leur texte leur voix leur souffle
grâce à des exercices de respiration
d'étirements de mise en mouvement du
texte de positionnement de placement
et très vite plus que le spectacle c'est
le chemin pour y arriver qui m'a
intéressé on savait tous mes amis
acteurs et moi-même que la force
intérieure du comédien vient de la
commande centrale du mouvement ici dans
le centre de gravité
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré les
arts martiaux grâce à mon training de
comédienne
l'Aïkido d'abord
qui m'enseignait que l'énergie est comme
un flux qui ne doit jamais s'interrompre
d'ailleurs on chute est tellement par
entraînement que je n'avais même pas
peur de tomber
et puis le
premier maître était très âgé
il avait survécu aux prisons chinoises
11 ans d'emprisonnement sous la
Révolution culturelle grâce au Tahiti
je l'ai rencontré à Berlin
on s'entraînait dans la neige et par
tous les temps on avait les jours roses
et les mains brûlantes
comme si rien ne pouvait plus nous
atteindre
c'est là que j'ai eu mes premiers frères
d'armes
et puis un jour le professeur de
médecine chinoise avec qui je pratiquais
le chi kong à Strasbourg a donné un
séminaire extraordinaire
ça parlait de l'alchimie interne taoïste
c'était une méthode pratiquée en
financière par des personnes
exceptionnelles qu'on appelait des êtres
montagnes tiens
pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient tellement
enracinés dans leur pied qu'on ne
pouvait les pousser
et l'exercice phare de cette méthode
était le sourire intérieur il consistait
à sourire à tous ces organes
son cœur ses poumons son foi s'arrête
ses reins les organes à l'intérieur du
bassin
c'était comme une révélation pour moi
tout se révélait de l'intérieur tout se
ranimait et tout ce que j'avais vécu
prenait tellement de sens
partir de là je ne suis plus jamais
arrêté de pratiquer je m'étais acheté
vous savez un de ces petits à fous ces
petits coussins de méditation
et tous les matins dans ma petite
chambre d'étudiante je pratiquais le
sourire intérieur
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour j'étais sur mon
vélo à Strasbourg au feu rouge
j'attendais patiemment que le feu passe
au vert
et là mes organes m'ont souri de
l'intérieur
c'était comme un feu qui monte du dedans
c'était incroyable je suis resté j'ai
oublié de passer au feu vert toutes les
voitures montent klaxonné j'ai dû me
garer sur le côté
et d'un stand de grâce en instant de
grâce j'ai mené une vie pleinement à
West je voyageais à pied je me faisais
du stop que quand c'était nécessaire je
dormais sous les étoiles
et je visitais les endroits les plus
beaux du monde où la nature était la
plus belle
la nature monoret de sa beauté elle me
faisait rayonner de l'intérieur
elle illuminait ma vitalité
savez-vous qu'il est maintenant prouvé
scientifiquement que si vous bivouaciez
trois semaines entières et dormez
entièrement sous les étoiles vous faites
un reset complet de votre ADN
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
j'ai changé ma carte d'identité
énergétique c'est mon histoire
et bravant toutes les intempéries je
suis allée à la rencontre de se mettre
qui enseignait le sourire intérieur de
par le monde
je l'ai trouvé
je suis allé à son séminaire et là il
n'y avait que des thérapeutes et des
personnes spirituellement très avancées
mais moi je sentais tout ce qui disait
je sentais dans mes cellules j'étais sûr
c'était une évidence pour moi que c'est
intelligence primordiale d'en parler le
Tao était là pour réintégrer l'humain au
Grand Tout et à son tout intérieur
et pendant le séminaire ce grand maître
taoïs que je ne connaissais ni d'EV ni
d'Adam
est passé près de moi et m'a dit dans
l'oreille
ton énergie est bonne
ça m'a porté pendant 30 ans
je suis devenu enseignante
et puis j'ai créé ma propre école
c'est sans doute ce qui m'a permis de
rencontrer le chaman sur le chemin
qui m'a donné trois indices comme dans
les contes initiatiques
il m'a dit Fabienne tu dois retrouver
trois choses la première tu dois à
nouveau te laisser pousser les cheveux
la deuxième tu dois retrouver tes armes
la troisième tu dois rejoindre l'océan
et je l'ai fait j'ai laissé pousser mes
cheveux
j'ai rencontré le kung-fu j'ai étudié
les armes traditionnelles chinoises
que je pratique d'ailleurs toujours et à
30 ans je me suis remise à nager je suis
devenue nageur sauveteur
j'ai surveillé les plages de France
pendant 7 ans et c'est ce qui m'a permis
de rencontrer l'amour
d'arriver dans le Pacifique et de
devenir maman à mon tour
une vie bien remplie me direz-vous
vécu à 100%
je suis bien d'accord avec vous mais une
chose compte pour moi c'est que j'ai
trouvé ma solidité intérieure ma vérité
ma sécurité là dans mon ventre
dans la force motrice de mon
accomplissement
ce soir j'ai envie de vous partager
trois clés qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
la première
ayez confiance dans votre histoire
si vous la reconstituez vous trouverez
que dans chaque élément qui la constitue
il y a un petit bout du fil rouge qui
vous conduira à votre quintessence votre
essence le sens même de votre vie et
puis nous craignez pas d'être blessé
chaque blessure est presque une
bénédiction elle vous mènera plus loin
plus haut que vous n'imaginez
pourquoi parce que chaque blessure
contient une peur et que si vous
l'affrontez vous réalisez votre alchimie
vous transformez votre plan en or
et en dernier je parlerai d'intégrer la
sagesse des cycles vit mort
et vie
car si nous sommes bien cet organisme
naturel
ce microcosme contenu dans un organisme
naturel beaucoup plus grand ce
macrocosme qu'on appelle la nature
comme elle nous avons nos cycles
intérieurs nous avons un printemps un
été un automne et un hiver
une chose est sûre c'est qu'après
l'hiver
le printemps revient toujours
pour finir je citerai une phrase que
j'aime beaucoup de Claude lard sinologue
et grand précurseur en matière de
médecine traditionnelle chinoise en
France
car vivre enfin
c'est n'avoir pas peur de vivre merci
[Applaudissements]